you mean more chair traveling there
contemplating because we had a very fair
process in the House of Representatives
that of your to our I let me just put
another way we will will have we have
legislation approved by the rules
committee that will enable us to decide
how we will send it over with articles
of impeachment we cannot make managers
until we see what the process is on the
Senate side and I would hope that that
will be soon as we did with our
legislation or as a 1862 describe what
the process would be so far we haven't
seen anything that will expire to us so
hopefully it will be fair and when we
see what that is they will make the
decision as a group as we always have as
we go along
[Music]
well again we'll decide of what that
dynamic is but we hope that the
resolution of all that process will be
soon in the center well let me tell you
what I don't consider it well I don't
consider it a fair trial this is what I
don't consider a trill fair trial that
leader McConnell has stated that he's
not an impartial juror that he's going
to take his cues and quotes from the
White House and he is working in total
coordination with the White House
counsel's office let me just say that
obviously Senator McConnell by that
declaration has said that he is so in
effect the foreman of the jury is
working with the defendants counsel
that's not fair and we'll have to see
what else but that's certainly an
indication of an unfair of an intention
to have an unfair trial it's up to the
Senators to recommend to make their own
decision working together hopefully in
recognition of their witnesses that the
president withheld from us their
documents that the president withheld
from us and we would hope that that
information would be there available in
a trial to go to the next step because
that's another level in terms of
conviction into
but right now the president we're not
having that discussion loose we we have
done what we have set out to do the
house has acted on a very sad day to
protect and defend the Constitution of
the United States to do so in a manner
that was fair
even though the other side was
mischaracterizing it nonetheless it was
fair and appropriate and urgent and
urgent so we know what made our decision
as to one we're going to send when we
see what they're doing on the Senate
side but that's a decision that we will
make jointly you're starting to act like
another country don't you okay he's not
going to question I'm not that would
have been our intention but we'll see
what what happens over there you're
asking me are we all going to go out and
play in the snow this guy has not been
part of our conversation that has not
been part of our conversation excuse me
what I'm sorry
now I never raise the prospect you ask
the question I never raised the prospect
I said we're not sending it to night
because it's difficult to determine who
the managers would be until we see the
arena and which we will be participating
that's all I said
I never raised the prospect well we'll
see what they when they come forward and
it's up to the center to say it says
they want what their rules will be my
comments do you wanna say anything about
this because it is yo this is a serious
matter even though the majority leader
in the United States Senate says it's
okay for the foreman of the jury to be
coming for votes with the lawyers of the
accused that doesn't sound right to us
but let's see when they understand what
we have acted now one they'll understand
what their responsibilities are and
we'll see what that is but I never
raised that possibility
but anyway let me again thank our
Chairman all six of them and our darling
Elijah they did a remarkable job and I
think you probably hopefully will be
inspired by the moral courage of our
caucus especially as the distinguished
chairman recognized our freshman members
who came here revealed that reviewed the
facts understood the Constitution made
their decision again to honor their oath
of office